Good morning Hank; it’s Friday. Today’s
video is actually like Voldemort’s soul
because it comes to you in eight parts. It
is also like the cake, because it is, at least
partly, a lie. That’s right, Hank, it’s
April Fool’s Day. One of these eight parts
is a lie. You will either guess the lie or
I will have fooled you, which will make me
the winner of an arbitrary contest of my own
creation! Which is my favorite kind of game
to win.
Part one: Hank, Nerdfighters have done so
much research into the great and terrible
library of Ivan the Terrible that we are now
the largest resource on the entire internet
on the topic. And the story they’ve uncovered
is crazy, Hank, it involves, like, fire-proof
dungeons and crucified skeletons and a supposedly-blind
architect! It’s like National Treasure only
it’s real and the role of Nicholas Cage
is played by nerds.
Speaking of Nicholas Cage, Hank, part two:
Nicholas Cage has a son named Kal-El, like
the birth name of Superman, his name is Kal-El
Coppola Cage because, you know, Nick Cage
is cousins with Sofia Coppola, who by the
way made The Virgin Suicides into a movie,
a book written by Jeffrey Eugenides, whose
facial hair may or may not be a joke.
Part three: also, while we’re on the topic
of celebrities, Michael J. Fox’s middle
name? Andrew.
Part four: Hank, I hate being one of those
parents who brags, but Henry spoke his first
multiple-word sentence this week, and it was
very cute. I was like “hi” and he was
like “hi” and I was like “hi” and
he was like “hi” and I was like “hi”
and then he looked me deep in the eyes and
he said “Hi, cat!”
Part five: Hank, you probably know that Marie
Curie is the only person to win a Nobel Prize
in both chemistry and physics, but did you
know that her daughter Irene also won a Nobel
Prize, making her the only Nobel Prize winner
who is the mother of a Nobel Prize winner?
It’s a fact, Hank! Or is it? Also, Hank,
Marie Curie had a sister named Bronislawa.
It’s hard out there for a Bronislawa. Hank,
this is off-topic but I will pay you one American
dollar if you write a song about Marie Curie’s
sister called “It’s Hard Out There for
a Bronislawa.”
Part six: Hank, you may remember that I purchased
Warner Chilcott stock after Warner Chilcott
Warner Chilcotted you and other people with
ulcerative colitis. Well Hank, I sold that
stock today for a twenty-six dollar profit!
I’m on a roller coaster that only goes up,
baby! Hank, I don’t think I’ve ever felt
worse about making twenty-six dollars. I’d
like to use that money to decrease Worldsuck,
preferably in a way that Warner Chilcotts
Warner Chilcott. Nerdfighters, if you have
any ideas, leave them in comments.
Part seven: Hank, people say my fear of heights
is irrational, but do you know what’s the
most common cause of non-fatal emergency room
visits between the ages of 25 and 34? Unintentional
fall! And heights are the most common cause
of unintentional falls, meaning that heights
are the greatest non-fatal problem facing
members of our generation! So Hank, let that
be a lesson to you: do not put yourself in
a situation where you could fall unintentionally.
Part eight: Hank even though you’re like,
successful and grown up and everything, do
you know that if you Google image search your
name, this is the second result?
So that’s it, seven truths and one lie!
Nerdfighters, leave your guess in comments.
I hope you don’t get fooled! Hank, you’re
a tomato. I’ll see you on Monday.
P.S. Nerdfighters, if you haven’t seen Hank’s
video about the Ice Cream Chords, your mind
is about to be blown. Click anywhere on the
screen and find out why Rebecca Black and
Slipknot have some surprising things in common.